being human is always directed and
pointing to
something other than itself he had been
blessed with a gifted mind he didn't fit
into any conventional sense into
anything life in principle never ceases
the whole demeaning for each and every
process to the American public though
he's best known to his book man's search
for meaning but as so far sold over a
million copies alone in this country a
genius with the simplest of tastes he
was almost like a child and his purposes
were always therapeutical I felt the
exact same way when I lay in that
hospital bed as he did when he was in a
concentration camp y me dijo ESO fue la
casa de mis padres de la que yo sali y
nunca mas believe me he didn't get
fixated on the past and wanted to build
towards the future the barriers between
people and religious groups were
irrelevant to him he was sorry for them
decency if I beasting to help them
that's good cessfully getting that shown
what up how's Vegas it didn't sit well
in many circles he doesn't get the
recognition he deserves because he never
care about it nobody is capable of fully
understanding dr. Frankel and what he
endured
you